As we all try to make sense of Season 2's
huge cliffhanger, there's one character who
may be much more important to the future of
the Umbrella Academy than any of us realised.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining why Harlan could
well be a secret member of the Sparrow Academy,
and revealing hidden clues to his potential
backstory with the Commission.
Obviously, spoilers ahead so take care.
In Harlan's very last scene of Season 2, we
see him leaving Dallas with his mother Sissy.
And although Vanya had seemingly withdrawn
the powers she transferred to him when he
drowned, the final moment left us in no doubt
that Harlan has retained some of her telekinetic
powers.
And we saw him levitating his little wooden
bird, a strong pointer to a connection between
him and the Sparrow Academy.
But what would be Harlan's role in the Sparrow
team?
Although he's just a young boy in 1963, 56
years later in 2019 Harlan would be well over
sixty years old.
So, rather than Harlan getting recruited by
Hargreeves in 1989 when the other super-babies
are born,
it's more likely that Hargreeves finds out
about Harlan if the young boy's superpowers
show up again later in the 60s.
They could begin to work together to set up
a new superhero team, with Harlan becoming
a superhero who dubs himself The Sparrow after
his favourite toy.
And that could lead Hargreeves to name the
Sparrow Academy in Harlan's honour, especially
if he dies on a mission, similar to young
Ben in the original timeline.
An alternative is that in this new timeline,
the origin of the super-babies is changed
and rather than being born spontaneously as
in the original timeline,
Harlan is the Sparrows' father and they inherited
their powers from him.
The glowing lights that Hargreeves released
in the finale of Season 1 appear to be behind
both Vanya and Harlan's powers, given that
we saw her transfer them into Harlan.
So, just as Vanya was able to reproduce her
powers in another person, what's to say that
Harlan can't do the same and pass on his powers
to others too?
If Harlan were to die, as I mentioned just
before, he could still live on inside the
mysterious green cube that floats alongside
the Sparrows on the balcony in the finale.
Now, I know this may sound crazy, but it's
not outside the bounds of possibility in the
bonkers world of the Umbrella Academy
where we've already had a talking, smoking
goldfish living in a fishbowl attached to
a robotic body.
We know Harlan has telekinetic powers and
can therefore make objects float, so it's
interesting that the cube not only floats
into view, but it also glows inside hinting
that it may be sentient.
And, curiously, the first time we see Harlan
in the show, he's actually wearing green.
Indeed, there's a precedent for something
similar to this in another superhero show,
Doom Patrol.
In that DC show, the body of Cliff Steele
was destroyed beyond repair in a car accident,
however, his brain was salvaged, kept alive
and put into a robot body, turning him into
Robotman.
And the Doom Patrol comics were a major influence
on Gerard Way when he wrote the original Umbrella
Academy comics.
So, even if Harlan were fatally wounded on
a mission, Hargreeves could have saved his
consciousness and transferred it into the
cube.
We've already seen Hargreeves save Luther
from death by injecting him with a serum that
changes his physiology into something more
ape-like.
And in Season 2, Hargreeves also brought Pogo
back from the dead in a similar way.
Alternatively, Harlan could still be alive
and using his powers to control the cube himself.
Another possibility hinted at within the show
is that Harlan becomes involved with the Commission.
When his powers blew up in the penultimate
episode of Season 2, it showed up as a major
timeline anomaly on the Commission's Infinite
Switchboard.
The Handler immediately recognised the significance
of this event, and she told Harlan that she
could take him somewhere that would understand
and help him.
"I can take you to a place where you will
be properly understood, listened to, even
without a voice.
I can tap into your potential, and together,
just the two of us, we can do incredible things."
Now, Harlan may have only spoken a few times
in Season 2, but it was shown that he could
understand the conversations around him and
whatever was being said to him.
So, the Handler's words to him may well have
planted an idea or a question in his mind
about who she was, where she came from and
what the place was that she was referring
to.
We also know in the finale from Herb that
the Commission will be looking for a new board
of directors and therefore a new head of the
organisation.
So, when Harlan's powers likely show up again
on the Infinite Switchboard, I expect the
Commission to take an interest in him again.
He may even get recruited to work for them,
similar to how the Handler recruited Five
as a Commission agent in the first season.
In fact, Harlan's name may actually be a reference
to Andrew Harlan, the protagonist from Isaac
Asimov's The End of Eternity, a novel which
has some incredible parallels with The Umbrella
Academy.
The End of Eternity is a time-travel story
in which people called the Eternals run an
organisation that exists outside of time
and manipulates events throughout history
to create and maintain what they see as an
optimum timeline that will bring about the
maximum good for humanity.
Ring any bells so far?
"So the Commission controls time?"
"More like we maintain the correct timeline,
but basically yeah."
"We are tasked with the preservation of the
time continuum through manipulation and removals."
In Asimov's novel, Harlan is an Eternal and
Technician who makes modifications to the
human timeline.
And I can't help but think that the connection
between The Umbrella Academy's Temps Commission,
or as it's called in the comics,
and Asimov's Eternals hints at Harlan ending
up at the Commission in some way, maybe even
taking charge.
And if he does, perhaps he will become instrumental
in ensuring the Commission follows a policy
that leads to the creation of the Sparrow
Academy.
Another small but important detail from the
finale of season 2 is that as Sissy and Harlan
leave Texas for California, we see them crossing
the state border into New Mexico.
New Mexico is, of course, en route from Texas
to California, but it's interesting that the
series choses to show us this particular moment
in the journey,
because it means that Sissy and Harlan could
be passing near to the site of the Roswell
UFO incident which has been the subject of
numerous UFO and alien conspiracy theories.
The Umbrella Academy already made allusions
to various JFK assassination conspiracy theories
in Season 2,
and given the reveal of Hargreeves as an alien,
the show may be hinting at something strange
happening to Harlan as he passes through New
Mexico.
Could he be intercepted by the Commission,
or somebody connected to the now deceased
Majestic 12 or some other nefarious organisation?
We've got numerous possibilities pointing
towards Harlan either setting up or helping
form the Sparrow Academy, perhaps even being
the cube member of the team,
but is there anything that suggests that he'll
be a future antagonist in the series?
Well, it's interesting to note that at the
end of Season 2, when new Ben arrives on the
scene, he's immediately rude and hostile towards
the Umbrella team.
"Dad, who the hell are these assholes?"
We know that Reginald Hargreeves is a cold
and unforgiving father as we've seen in flashbacks
from both seasons.
And he even admitted to Luther that he has
a deep dislike of children.
And given how he reacted to the Umbrella team
that he met in 1963.
"I've seen about enough."
It's clear that he must have decided to form
the Sparrow Academy with very different children.
Given the way new Ben has turned out in comparison
to the much more gentle Ben from the first
two seasons, it seems like this new group
may have grown up with a nastier and colder
edge to them.
Which is why the Sparrows and possibly Harlan
may turn out to be Season 3's antagonists.
On the outside, they may seem to be superheroes,
but behind the scenes they may have a darker
side, similar perhaps to the corrupt nature
of the superheroes in The Boys.
We should also remember that Harlan inherited
Vanya's powers and she became an antagonist
in the first season due to the way she'd been
treated by her father and family.
In situations of extreme emotional distress,
Vanya's powers can spiral out of control,
something we also saw when she was being tortured
by the FBI in Season 2.
Harlan also went supernova when he accidentally
caused the death of his father after his powers
deflected a bullet into Carl.
However, after Vanya extracted the lights
from Harlan, he seems to be calmer and more
in control, but we don't know whether he can
keep the powers in check if some kind of tragedy
strikes again.
What if the authorities come after Sissy and
him when they investigate Carl's death and
try to take her away from him, for instance?
Of course, I don't think it's at all certain
that Harlan will end up on the dark side,
especially because in all of his Season 2
scenes with Vanya, he seemed sweet and sensitive.
Still, there is something a little ominous
about the final scene as we see him and Sissy
cross the border into New Mexico.
And if you want to learn more about the various
conspiracies that were referenced in Season
2, as well as all of the secret Sparrow symbols
hidden throughout the season,
tap here to watch my Things You Missed video
or follow the link in the video description.
So, who do you think Harlan will turn out
to be in Season 3?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed this video a thumbs-up
is hugely appreciated.
Tap left for a full explanation of everything
in Season 2 including the ending, the Umbrella
Academy's time travel rules and multiverse,
who the Sparrow Academy really are and all
the new powers that were revealed.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!